dans ce salon de thé aux allures
britannique décoration gêne-t-elle je
vais côtoyer fauteuil et gâteaux haut en
couleurs les salons de valentina créé il
y a un an par valentina elle-même se
situe au coeur de mantes la jolie c'est
un salon t
pour n'avait pas dix rifaie maison des
familles sont dans l'esprit un peu
british c'est un concept ou
c'est à la fois implanté à la fois un
endroit une visserie fine mais à la fin
on le questionne ses très chaleureuses
et conviviales
où puis ce qui est bien ce qui est à
tous les âges y ait beaucoup de
personnes âgées il ya des personnes
beaucoup plus jeune voilà c'est un
endroit pour tout le monde en fait
ouvert depuis un an elle a réalisé le
projet de ses rêves en créant son
entreprise dont elle avait l'idée depuis
plusieurs années pour commencer elle a
fait appel au bg e des yvelines c'est un
réseau de conseillers qui accompagne et
forme les nouveaux entrepreneurs dans la
création de leur entreprise c'est un
concept il fonctionne notre bien parce
que il est de a à z donc il conseille à
la fois dans le business plan à la fois
dans le chai recherches sur des fonds
des subventions une aide bienvenue pour
elle qui comme beaucoup d'autres jeunes
entrepreneurs peinent à savoir où et
comment commencer en tant que débutant
qu'il noue
n'a jamais eu entre on n'a jamais été
entrepreneur
homebrew c'est c'est vraiment un
labyrinthe dans lequel on rentre et on a
besoin d'un guide
à la fois pour démarches administratives
financiers se sont pas seuls en fait on
se sent idées et on perd pas de temps et
on peut perdre les moyens on peut perdre
aussi de la motivation pour nous tous
une concrétisation encourageante pour
cette récente chef d'entreprise plein de
projets je conseille vraiment à ceux qui
veulent créer ont créé un salon ou
autres
de aller jusqu'au bout de leur nez c'est
un petit cocon chaleureux jeu vous
donnera peut-être envie à votre tour de
vous lancer dans l'aventuré